hey youtubers is Charlie and we're
getting ready for Episode four Game of
Thrones so for my bonus video this week
I actually wanted to travel into the
past and pick you know one of the really
big characters that we haven't learned a
lot about yet and just talk about him
namely the Bloodraven since the show
kind of glosses over and changes a lot
of things though this video is just kind
of meant to fill in some of those gaps
in case you have read any of the books
please be careful whenever you write
stuff in the comments just add spoiler
tags if you're finding me for the first
time I'm just doing weekly bonus videos
before each episode airs be sure to
subscribe to get everything and leave me
suggestions for extra things you think I
should do videos on in the future so
let's get started the Bloodraven is not
actually his real name his real name is
Brendan rivers so for most of this video
that's what I'm gonna call him just
because it's a little bit easier most of
the early part of his life revolved
around the Blackfyre rebellion that was
the Great War started when Aegon
Targaryen the fourth legitimized all of
his bastards and gave one of them the
famous Targaryen sword named Blackfyre
the person who was supposed to become
king flipped-out civil war erupted as it
tends to do in Westeros interestingly
enough though that black fire sword that
was given to the bastard that belonged
to Aegon Targaryen was only one of two
famous Targaryen swords the other one
belonged to his older sister visenya
targaryen it was called dark sister that
was given to Brynden rivers after all
the black fire drama one of the bastards
actually survived and went on to found
the golden company remember how in
Episode three sir Davos talked about
maybe using them on the show that's
going to be like a whole different bonus
video I'll do it just gives you an idea
of how people in the story are connected
across time and space
just like Brynden rivers he lived for a
long long time so his history crosses
across a lot of the history of Westeros
up to where the show is right now he's
most notable for his appearance he does
only have one eye and his ability to use
magic most of his peers during his time
in Westeros thought of him as a sorcerer
you know they didn't trust him like sir
Davos might think of Melisandre as a
witch but his abilities his power set
included glamouring skin changing and
greensight glamouring is similar to what
you saw Jack and Huck are do whenever he
changed his face but because we really
don't know how he did that I'm gonna say
that what Jack and Hegar and the
faceless ones do to change their
appearance is do
print from clamoring but essentially
they both involved changing your face
skin changing we have seen on the show
quite a bit and we actually got that
cool first person shot of brand you know
when he was inside summer while he was
stalking prey greensight is mostly
referred to as the ability to have
visions of the future like being a
prophet some magic you can learn but
greensight is something you have to be
born with like bran just to give you an
idea of how rare it is to have that
ability it's only like one person in a
hundred thousand that's born with it so
it's super rare so you're starting to
understand why a lot of people thought
that Brynden rivers was like an evil
sorcerer and didn't trust them he had
all these abilities in addition to that
he held a lot of really powerful offices
plus there's the fact that he also got
Visenya x' ancestral blade dark sister
remember how much of a big deal it was
whenever Tywin melted down Ned Stark's
Valyrian blade and gave one to Jaime and
one to Joffrey everyone is jealous of
someone who possesses a Valyrian blade
and has magic so traveling all the way
back to the Blackfyre rebellion Brynden
rivers half-brother was the rightful
Targaryen air so he sided with the
loyalists so whenever they ended up
winning he got a spot on the small
Council eventually he became master of
whispers right now on the show that's
what Varys job is it's a lot like being
a spy master you know master of
information that's what Varys is talking
about every time he says you know a
little bird told me something so again
you can kind of see why people did not
trust Brynden rivers you know people
really hate Varys on the show and he
doesn't even have magic like Brendan had
he went on to become hand of the king
but because for some reason that job is
cursed he ended up getting thrown in the
black cells because the Targaryen king
at the time completely hated him
remember the black cells is essentially
that place underneath the red keep where
the king throws people that he just
wants to forget about he ended up
rotting in there for a long time but
remember whenever maester aemon told Jon
Snow about how he joined the Nights
Watch he was actually the brother of
another Targaryen King Aegon v
maester aemon story is like a whole
other bonus video and there's a lot
going on with that because he was
originally supposed to be king himself
but while master Amon was growing up and
until the time he went to the wall
burton rivers was still rotting down in
the black cells he was still alive so
whenever Amon went to the wall brillian
rivers was taken out of the black
and sent with him to the Nights Watch
Brendon obviously being really old at
this time ended up becoming Lord
Commander just like the old bear
eventually people just forgot about him
which is where the events on the show
pick up
so hopefully episode 4 will explain you
know what the show is gonna do with the
character whether or not it's going to
be different or like it is in the books
they change a lot of things so we'll
just have to wait and see so what I'm
really hoping is is they George our
Martin's new book world of Ice and Fire
which is a book that he's working on for
later this year is gonna fill in a lot
of gaps it's gonna be like the complete
history of Westeros or I guess as
complete as it can be you know with it
not being like a you know billion page
book we can talk more about that when
every releases it one of the fun things
about Game of Thrones and Song of Ice
and Fire is that there are so many
things you could literally spend all
your time talking about it if you've
read the dunk and egg books or the comic
books
Brendan Rivers was actually handed the
King what was going on but he's not
really part of those stories there is
also another really cool book that
Martin is tea is called fire and blood
and it's going to be the entire history
of the Targaryen family from Valyria all
the way to Daenerys he's not going to
write that until he's done with the last
Ice and Fire books but it'll fill in a
lot of gaps too but a big part of
Brynden rivers life gets tied up you
know in this kind of overarching war
between the red god and the great other
so we need to talk a little bit about
how magic intersects with those stories
the show has really just started to
touch on the gods you know using Mel
Sandra's character to kind of explain a
lot of things but I'm really interested
to see how the addition of the
greenseers and the children of the
forest get tied up and all that I kind
of like to think of them you know the
children of the forest and the green
seers is like this neutral force like
nature existing in between the two big
gods but it gets really complicated when
you start talking about the supernatural
forces in Westeros that's kind of the
way I think of the Bloodraven as like
this you know third thing going on off
to the side while you have White Walkers
and Melisandre focusing on their war
over on the other side and while he's
been off to the side here the really
cool thing is is that he's really gotten
to watch most of the history of Westeros
since the Blackfyre rebellion you know
he's kind of been there as this you know
silent force off to the side I think one
of my other bonus videos is going to
have to cover the children of the forest
just because they also have greensight
and that's really where things pick up
on the show we'll probably have to wait
to see how that plays out just because
the books haven't even covered a lot of
their history
one of the most fun things about you
know doing these bonus videos and doing
researches is that as you start doing
research on one person you end up having
to do research on like ten other people
because you know all the way from
Aegon's conquest to where we on the show
right now is totally connected and I
guess it's just really a testament to
george RR martin and good story planning
but now it's your turn let me know in
the comments below what are you most
excited to learn about on the show or in
the books you know personally i really
like to learn more about the children of
the forest
later tonight i'll be posting my episode
review be sure to subscribe to get it
and leave me suggestions for future
bonus videos my next one is probably
going to be on all the different tribes
the wildlings and how the show is
treating them so right now you can click
here to get my video for the episode
tonight I'll add the annotation as soon
as I post it and you can click here to
get my you know mega season 4 playlist I
have like a ton of Game of Thrones
videos so in case you haven't seen any
of them you can just browse through and
see what I've done thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you